الجدل الكبير في الاردن بسبب كتاب رسمي او
تعميم من احدى المدارس الخاصه للمعلمات
اللي شغالين فيها فالمدرسه طالبت معلماتها
بطلب غريب عجيب قالت لهم نظموا حملكم عشان
ولادتكم تجي في الصيف يعني عطله المدارس
الصيفيه اللي بتكون خلال اشهر سته وسبعه
وثمانيه يعني حددوا لهم هذه لازم تولدوا
في ذي الفتره يعني واضح ان المدرسه لقت
انه هذا حلها علشان ما تطلع المعلمات
اجازات او يطلعوا المعلمات لاجازات امومه
ويدوروا على معلمات بديلات وما الى ذلك
وبحسب كتاب المدرسه فالسبب هو ما تقتضيه
المصلحه العامه الكتاب صادر بتاريخ امس
وطبعا انتشر وبدات بعدها التعليقات فالناس
بدات تتساءل ايش هذه المدرسه او فين حقوق
المعلمات اصلا ان المعلمات ظروفهم صعبه
ورواتبهم اصلا قليله كمان يجي طلب عجيب
مثل هذا هذا غير المطالبات للوزاره بالتح
رك والتساؤلات حول قانونيه هذا القرار في
ناس كمان لقطت في التعميم اسم المدرسه
مجموعه مدارس الجامعه مثل مو شايفين
امامكم والناس دخلت لهم على بوستاتهم
انتقادات وتعليقات في المقابل كان في ناس
مو شايفه اي مشكله في القرار
المدرسه ردت في بيان للاعلام عن ونته لمن
يهمه الامر قالت فيه انه ورد لها سوره
التعميم مؤكده ان هذا التعميم لن يتم
العمل به ولا يمكن باي حال قبول مضمونه
وتؤكد المدارس على انها مؤسسه وتؤكد
المدرسه على انها مؤسسه التعليميه تلتزم
بالقوانين والانظمه المعمول بها وبتحترم
خصوصيه العاملين بها ايضا وقررت الاداره
فتح تحقيق موسع بخصوص البيان الصادر
ومحاسبه المسؤولين عنهم قال البيان كمان
انه التعميم الصدر هذا لا يعبر عن راي
اداره مدارس الجامعه بل هو قرار شخصي من
مصدره ولا يعتد به من اداره مدارس الجامعه
بشكل عام مديره المدرسه اللي موقعه على
التعميم صرحت للاعلام الاردني وقالت انه
صيغه التعميم كانت خاطئه لكن بررت الكتاب
بشكاوى من الاهالي بسبب اختلاف مستوى
التعليم اللي بيتلقاه اولادهم لمن
المعلمات يروحوا
فقالت كمان انه كان دافعها يعني مصلحه
الطلاب طيب ناس كثيره تساءلت عن موقف
وزاره التربيه من التعميم وعلشان كذا
تواصلنا معاهم ومعنا من عمان الدكتور احمد
المساعفه مدير التعليم العام والناطق
الاعلامي لوزاره التربيه والتعليم في
الاردن اهلا فيك معنا دكتور احمد طيب هل
هذا التعميم يعني طبيعي هل هو قانوني يعني
مقبول
مساء الخير ست ساره طبعا طلعتم تعميم اللي
صادر عن احدى المدارس الخاصه والذي يطلب
من المعلمات تنظيم فتره الحمل بحيث تكون
الولاده خلال الاشهر الصيف بحجه المحافظه
على سير العمليات التعليميه نحن في وزاره
التربيه والتعليم هذا الامر مرفوض رفضا
قاطعا ولا يمكن ان نقبل به لانه لا ينسجم
مع فلسفه وزاره التربيه والتعليم ومع
رسالتها ومع رؤيتها مع القيم التي تنادي
بها
بالانسانيه التي يجب ان يتحلى فيها الكادر
الاداري
وصاحب العمل اتجاه الموظفين هذه نحن رفضنا
هذا القرار رفضا قاطعا ايش ناوي تسووه سوف
نقوم بارسال فريق من اداره التعليم الخاص
الى المدرسه للوقوف على حيثيات الامر
واتخاذ الاجراءات المناسبه والتي تكفل حق
المعلمات في مم المهنه دون اي قيود عليهم
طيب دكتور احمد خليني اكون شويه صريحه معك
في كثير تعليقات بتقول انه وزاره التربيه
والتعليم في الاردن ما تحركت بخصوص هذا
التعميم الا لانه اصبح قضيه راي عام
والناس تداولت التعميم وما الى ذلك لكن في
قضايا اخرى اهم كمان حتى من هذه او كما
يعني وصفها الناس وزاره التربيه والتعليم
ما تحركت فيها مثل مثلا انه في بعض
المعلمات او كثير من المعلمات في المدارس
الخاصه بتم انقاف رواتبهم في شهور الصيف
مثلا انه المعلمين والمعلمات بشكل عام
رواتبهم منخفضه كيف بتردوا على هذا النقد
سيدتي بالنسبه لهذه الحاله هذا اول كتاب
يمر في تاريخ وزاره التربيه والتعليم ان
تقوم مدرسه خاصه بمخاطبه المعلمات بشكل
رسمي بهذا الامر وبالتالي مجرد ان وصل
الينا نسخه من الكتاب قمنا باصدار
التصريح الاعلامي حول هذا الامر اما
بالنسبه للملاحظات والشكاوى التي تريدنا
الى وزاره التربيه والتعليم حول المدارس
الخاصه فنحن ابوابنا مفتوحه وقلوبنا
مفتوحه لهذه الملاحظات وبالتالي مجرد ان
ياتي اي ملاحظه الى اداره التعليم الخاص
نقوم بمتابعتها
البعض يعني بس انتم في حاله التعميم
قررتوا انكم تاخذوا يعني تتصرف في الموضوع
على طول في الامور الاخرى من تنوين
تتصرفوا على طول بما انكم مدركين انه في
شكاوي من هذا النوع
لا احنا اي ملاحظه تاتينا الى وزاره
التربيه والتعليم فورا يقوم فريق من اداره
التعليم الخاص بزياره هذه المدرسه والوقوف
على حيثيات الامر واتخاذ القرار المناسب
نحن بما ان العقد شريعه المتعاقدين بين
المعلم وبين المدرسه وبالتالي واجبنا في
وزاره التربيه والتعليم ان نحافظ على
تنفيذ هذه العقود بما يحفظ سير العمليه
التعليميه من جهه وبما يحفظ حقوق المعلمين
والمعلمات من جهه اخرى طيب حضرتك نحن
عرضنا كمان اللي هو بيان المدرسه
وفي بشكل عام من
انه على شخص واحد او شخص واحد يعني
المديره يرموا عليها المسؤوليه وانه
المدرسه غير مسؤوله والكلام هذا كله طيب
هل ممكن العقوبه اللي ممكن تتخذوها بشان
المدرسه وهل برضه حيتم تخصيص العقوبه على
المديره اللي قيل انه هي اللي عملت هذا
التعميم
سيدتي هذا يتوقف على تنسيب الفريق الزائر
للمدرسه وبالتالي هو يرى هذه الامور
وبالتالي ينسب الى الوزاره باتخاذ الاجراء
المناسب لن
يكون هناك اي
محاباه ضد اي مدرسه لا تراعي حقوق
المعلمات وبالتالي نحن وزاره التربيه
والتعليم المظله الاكبر المظله مظله
التعليم التي يجب ان نحافظ على سير
العمليه التعليميه وبالتالي سير العمليه
التعليميه هو اولى اولوياتنا بما يحفظ
حقوق المعلمين وبما
نعالج هذه الملاحظات جمله وتفصيلا
على هذه المداخله كان معنا من عمان
الدكتور
[موسيقى]
احمد عامون نا
طق التربيه والتعليم في الاردن